it was a miracle escape just off the m25
PC Dan Pascoe and his colleague were
responding to a report of a stolen car
and the BMW smashed into them
not only did he survive the impact the
officer sprinted after the culprit and
brought him down with the Taser
I remember thinking this is going to be
close and you naturally sort of take a
step back or anything dangers coming and
and then all of a sudden all I remember
is I'm in the air looking down at the
tarmac ground thinking oh dear this
isn't turned out the way it was planned
sad a piece of equipment now for some
officers on the front line PC Pascal
confronted the car thief Lea Adamson who
tried to attack the officer but the
Taser rapidly ended his resistance he
ran down an embankment and tried to
climb over a fence and as he's climbing
over the fence I've got close enough to
him where he's trying to kick out at me
thankfully he missed because it would
have probably been about my head that
he'd hit and at that point it was when I
threw my taser and tasered him in the
back
Adamson from West London pleaded guilty
to several driving offences and
resisting arrest
he was jailed for 23 months sorry police
have since had calls from American TV
shows asking about PC Pascal's heroics
the force has condemned Adamson's
actions as appallingly irresponsible and
the Brady Sky News